là ce sont des traces de ce matin ça ce
sont des animaux qui sont sortis ce
matin sans aucun doute des sangliers de
plus en plus proche des routes
une présence qui s'explique par une
légère hausse de leur population mais
aussi parce qu'ils cherchent à se
nourrir
il trouve très peu de blanc et de vert
cette année dans les bois en ce moment
en touraine dans une bonne part de
sécheresse et l'humilité et encore moins
importante en forêt qu'elle ne l'est
dans la campagne et dans les champs et
donc les vers de terre sont moins
présents forêt que dans la queue dans
les champs c'est pourquoi on est sortis
de nos sangliers aujourd'hui qui va qui
vont dans les champs connectez essayez
de manger trouvé trouvé vers millet pour
trouver à manger également au bord des
routes les routes les bordures de routes
les berne sont toujours très propice
faire toujours un petit peu plus humide
depuis début octobre les gendarmes ont
recensé 33 collision de voiture avec du
gibier dont plus de la moitié avec des
sangliers
si les dégâts ne sont que matériels pour
l'instant les chiffres similaires à l'an
dernier sont en deçà de la réalité
alors pour éviter l'accident certains
s'équipe d'un avertisseur ultrasons vous
coller ce petit accessoire généralement
au niveau des rétroviseurs ans qui
permet avec le vent quand ils
s'engouffrent l'intérieur de créer un
signal à ultrason qui est perceptive
uniquement par les animaux sauvages et
d' incident signalé une présence d'un
déplacement cet avertisseur peut
s'avérer utile sur les trois
départementale accidentogènes qui
partent de tours vers chinon château
renault et neuillé-pont-pierre l'autre
solution reste la prudence
on doit adapter sa vitesse est resté
toujours mettre son vécu ça veut dire
qu'on peut aussi réduire sa vitesse à 80
km/heure quand on est loin d'une telle
zone boisée et adapté en prévision d'un
éventuel obstacle qui peut être un
animal sauvage et puis en cas
d'obstacles sur la route à freiner au
maximum en dernier conseil conduire le
plus possible en plein far et élargir
son champ de vision
[Applaudissements]